[Music]
located in the town of Pathan in India
is a 90 foot deep step well with an even
deeper connection to the past built
inside an opening in the ground
approximately 200 feet long and 65 feet
wide the step well is designed as a 7
level inverted temple throughout history
most monuments have been constructed by
men with the intention of honoring their
wives however Rani Kaval is different as
it was initially built as a memorial to
the king in the 11th century AD by his
wife hence it became known as the Queen
step while in the past deep wells were
common throughout India these walls were
primarily used to collect water however
they also became a place of socialising
and an important aspect of the community
- people of the time it features more
than 500 principal sculptures and at
least 1,000 smaller sculptures all in
religious or mythological imagery at the
trends peak there were roughly 3000
stepwells in India however today only
around a thousand remain Veronica Valle
serves as a valuable visual history to
teach and remind visitors about the
traditions of the past
[Music]